zac efron channels his inner Zack Morris
oh my god
my hero okay thanks
the 28 year old actor is still rocking
his seriously epic bleached tips showing
off his frosted locks on Wednesday in LA
at the premiere of his new comedy
Mike and Dave need wedding dates in
theatres July what we're about to do
something awesome he opened up to et on
the red carpet about his platinum do
alongside his co-star Adam Devine so
what inspired this look
it was Baywatch actually I did it for a
part and then I thought I had additional
photography in the next leg upcoming
week so I just kind of kept it and I
just talked to the producers and they
said that I don't have to reshoot
anything for about like a year so I've
just been having it for no reason and I
feel pretty your punk rock and rock
you're getting some Zack Morris
comparisons which is pretty cool oh my
god it's me Zack Zack and Adam are
officially our new bromance goals they
clearly have a tight and hilarious bond
oh you are like the nicest guy ever so
like there's nothing no jörgen I know
we're kind of being a little bit of it
right now though I was saying you were
nice because you were talking about me
about being nice you know you're nice
wasn't a real nice so in fact you're not
as nice I'll take it yeah I'm nicer you
know thank you
this argument never starts because it's
never gonna begin this conversations
over
yeah that's it done but